und jetzt nehmen wir sie mit in ein land
bei dem die welt seit wochen seit
monaten lieber weg schaut dass taliban
afghanistan unsere truppen sind dar
außerdem beherrschen die radikalen
islamisten die terroristen die langen
bärte wieder dieses land und unser
reporter paul ronzheimer der schaut hier
nicht weg vor drei monaten war er
zuletzt im taliban land das alles sind
bilder von ihm von damals als die
taliban also dieses land wieder
zurückgeholt haben da hat er der welt
berichtet welches drama sich dort
abspielt wie alle frauen von den straßen
verschwinden wie die scharia wieder
zurückgekehrt ist und wie die taliban
ihren sieg über den westen feiern
seitdem ist es nicht besser geworden in
afghanistan sondern schlechter
sie haben hunger und das jeden tag
unterernährten babys in den
krankenhäusern in afghanistan drei
monate nach der machtübernahme der
taliban stehen die menschen dort vor
einer erneuten krise dem hungertod und
1939 millionen einwohner in afghanistan
leiden darunter das schockierende daran
von ihnen sind laut hilfsorganisationen
auch mehr als eine million kinder davon
betroffen
wir sind in den krankenhäusern in
afghanistan unterwegs hier auf dieser
station werden kinder und babys versorgt
die unter mangelernährung leiden zu
hause für sie gibt es nicht genügend
essen und das ist ein dramatisches
problem dass immer mehr zunimmt ärzte
berichten uns dass hunderte kinder und
babys in den vergangenen wochen und
monaten gestorben sind viele müssen
behandelt werden das problem so sagt
einer der ober ärzte hier ist dass sie
nicht mehr genug geld haben um genügend
auch medizinisches material einzukaufen
bild zu besuch auf der kinderstation in
wada keine nachbarprovinz von kabul die
lage ist schlimm erklärt dr abdelhakim
immer wieder gäbe es todesfälle die
babys sind unterernährt und es könnte in
den nächsten monaten noch dramatischer
werden es gibt nicht genug medizin und
kaum noch hilfen für die menschen vor
ort
überall liegen abgemagerte und
schreiende babys in den betten sie
werden von ihren müttern versorgt die
teilweise überfordert wirken
mannis erhält ihr sechs monate altes
baby im arm rasant wiegt gerade mal drei
kilogramm viel zu wenig für das halter
es besteht lebensgefahr
wie bei vielen anderen auch es gibt nur
eins was jetzt wichtig ist hilfe und das
schnell denn ohne sie könnte es für die
kinder ein harter winter werden
und wir sprechen jetzt mit paul
ronzheimer unserem bild reporter in
afghanistan grüße dich paul lasst uns
diese schlimmen bilder mitgebracht aus
dem taliban afghanistan wir schauen dort
in die augen von hungernden von völlig
unterernährten kranken kindern und am
ende steht ein hilferuf war wie sollen
wir helfen ohne den taliban zu helfen
das ist die entscheidende frage die sich
alle stellen die internationale
gemeinschaft die mit afghanistan zu tun
hat und die wir hier auch den menschen
auf der straße stellen in kabul der
hauptstadt afghanistans dann ist es
völlig unklar wenn geld kommen wo geht
das geld hin ich glaube die einzige
chance ist es über hilfsorganisation
internationale hilfsorganisation zu
machen also uno world food programm aber
auch das muss dann tatsächlich mit einer
sicherheitsgarantie passieren diese
menschen die leute die für
internationale organisationen arbeiten
haben alle noch angst hierher
zurückzukommen weil sie nicht wissen wie
reagieren die taliban wirklich auf sie
es gab zuletzt ein überfall auf
hilfsorganisationen die versucht haben
nahrung auszuliefern das ist das problem
das sozusagen auch die taliban hier in
kabul am ende nicht für das ganze land
sprechen können wer weiß was ein anderer
einer anderen provinz passiert heute
warst bei der nacht machtübernahme oder
kurz danach auch im land und jetzt bist
du wieder dort beschreiben uns einmal
wie sich in diesen wochen in diesen
monaten das land verändert hat was zu
beobachten kannst auf den straßen in den
darf
das land hat sich massiv verändert im
vergleich zu dem was vor drei monaten
war mein gefühl ist die taliban sind
noch präsenter geworden man sieht
weniger frauen auf den straßen ich höre
von frauen zum beispiel anwältin die
nicht mehr arbeiten dürfen den verruf
berufsverbot ausgesprochen wurde ich
höre von schulkindern die weiterhin
nicht in die schule dürfen denn ab 12
sind die meisten schulen geschlossen für
mädchen für frauen die taliban sagen ja
im nächsten jahr wird das irgendwann
passieren aber diese versprechung die
sind viele menschen leid gleichzeitig
sind hier in kabul im untergrund immer
noch viele menschen die angst haben dass
die taliban rache nehmen könnten also
sie verstecken sich in den häusern
weiter weil sie nicht rauskommen aus dem
land japan und gleichzeitig suchen die
taliban nach partnern für ihre geschäfte
und da haben sie sich ausgerechnet auch
die ampel regierung die neue deutsche
bundesregierung ausgeguckt die ja
cannabis freigeben möchte und da wittern
die taliban jetzt neue geschäfte wir
schauen uns einmal an auf das was er
gerade dir erzählt hat nämlich der
sprecher des taliban innenministers das
hat er dir gesagt zu diesen möglichen
geschäften mit der deutschen regierung
eine drogen firma will in afghanistan
investieren wir sprechen mit ihnen
wie ist das unternehmen mit ihnen in
kontakt getreten über die genauen
verknüpfung weiß ich nicht aber was
wichtig für uns ist sie investieren in
afghanistan und das ist wichtig für uns
dass weltweit länder in afghanistan
investieren ist wichtig um afghanischen
menschen zu helfen jobs hier zu finden
und sind sie offen für eine kooperation
wenn unternehmen in afghanistan
investieren so dass sie eine kooperation
mit gras cannabis machen können um es
diesen vieren zu verkaufen import export
nach deutschland
die vereinbarung ist noch nicht
abgeschlossen
nächstes mal werden wir es genauer
erklären
sind sie optimistisch
sehen sie gute möglichkeiten der
kooperation mit deutschland aufgrund der
legalisierung von cannabis und gras
ja wir laden investoren der ganzen welt
ein in afghanistan zu investieren
wenn wir ihnen das vertrauen geben dass
afghanistan sicher ist
also mein job ist es ihnen zu vermitteln
dass die sicherheitssituation gut ist
paul ronzheimer uns zugeschaltet aus
afghanistan noch bei uns der auch mit
dem innenministerium der taliban
gesprochen hat die sich einen deal
erhoffen wie glaubst du wird man darauf
reagieren es ist ja immer die große
frage wie kann man den menschen im land
helfen was kann man auch gegen die
taliban tun und viele viele politiker
sind sich da auch nicht ganz einig wie
die vorgehensweise die richtige sein
könnte in diesem sehr schwierigen spagat
also patricia vielleicht erstmal zu
diesem cannabis stil das ist wirklich
eine total verrückte geschichte ist sein
deutsches unternehmen der deutsche chef
sitzt in kirgisistan hat immer mal
wieder auch geschäfte mit bestimmten
regime gemacht und der hat über einen
mittelsmann hier in kabul kontakt
aufgenommen mit der afghanischen
regierung und hat gesagt wie wäre es
denn wenn weder zusammenarbeiten also
cannabis produkte herstellen dann
sozusagen cannabis dann nach deutschland
und andere länder auch zu importieren da
geht es auch um medizinische produkte
und da haben die taliban gesagt ja da
sind wir eigentlich ganz offen für wenn
ihr denn hier investiert das von einem
400 millionen deal die rede also dass
diese deutsche firma 400 millionen in
eine fabrik steckt in afghanistan oder
sprecher zu mir gesagt dann sei man auch
bereit denen eine art monopol zu geben
also das läuft dann noch ganz einfach
wenn es denn so einfach wäre das ist es
nämlich nicht denn die internationale
gemeinschaft die verbietet momentan
geschäfte hier mit den taliban die
regierung ist nicht anerkannt das heißt
wenn eine deutsche firma hier geschäfte
machen würde dann würde sie das in große
probleme und stürzen das würde
wahrscheinlich sanktionen geben und die
produkte würden auch nicht zumindest auf
legalem wege nach deutschland kommen
also das ist das eine große probleme
aber die andere frage und da hast du ja
recht wie geht man jetzt um mit den
taliban die frage ist kann man mit denen
sprechen da gab es einen besuch von
markus poetzel dass es der
sonderbeauftragte der solche wieder
botschafter werden aber die botschaften
sind nicht offen und es ist so ein
bisschen eine
man weiß nicht genau was man tun soll
die internationale gemeinschaft steht
dort und sieht wie die probleme hier
weiterhin vorhanden sind wie die taliban
sich nicht ändern wie sie sich nicht
ändert bei frauenrechten und bei vielen
anderen minderheitsrechte aber wie
gleichzeitig die armut im land massiv
zunimmt ihr habt die bilder von
angesprochen und das ist ein moralisches
dilemma in dem der westen jetzt steckt
und um das noch mal richtig zu verstehen
es kommt tatsächlich in afghanistan bei
der afghanischen regierung an was hier
im koalitionsvertrag steht also wenn man
sich hier darauf vorbereitet neue
freizügige regelungen für cannabis zu
schaffen da kommt dass da in kabul
wirklich an
das kommt auf indirektem wege in kabul
an in dieser deutsche investor diese
deutsche firma die hat wiederum kontakt
aufgenommen hier mit afghanistan mit
kabul und da hat man natürlich auch
immer diese dinge gesprochen wobei den
taliban es sind wahrheit natürlich egal
ist wohin dann diese produkte gehen ob
sie nach deutschland gehen oder in die
niederlande wo das ganze ja schon länger
legalisiert ist sie wollen einfach nur
das überhaupt wirtschaft entsteht ich ob
auch gehört vom wirtschaftsminister dass
man verzweifelt versucht irgendetwas zu
finden wie man zusammenarbeit machen
kann denn die taliban wissen der druck
in der bevölkerung wird natürlich immer
größer sie müssen irgendwie es schaffen
die menschen auch hier wieder in arbeit
zu bringen denn die hunger rate also die
menschen die hungern ist so massiv die
gibt in die große mehrheit auch in die
mittelschicht der afghanischen
bevölkerung
paul ronzheimer aus afghanistan vielen
herzlichen dank dir für deine berichte